right good afternoon everyone welcome to
this cabinet meeting of 7th of february
do we have any apologies for absent son
none
no apologies for absence do we have any
disclosures of interest
no
uh minutes confirm and sign the minutes
of the meetings held on 10th and 17th of
june are there any issues on the minutes
please
check charlie january
slip of the brain
now
good
so i will assign those uh later
so moving on
uh i have to
inform members of cabinet we have one
item of urgent business which is the
approval of a loan
to spring housing for the thread winter
project
and i would like to say that item for
the gateway purchase options
we will take
most of that in private session so i'm
going to
take that agenda item last
so that we move into private session and
then everything else is dealt with
so before we move on to item five are
there any other issues members of
council sorry members of cabinet
no
revenue and capital budget 2022 23 to 26
27
councillor harvey
thank you mr chairman
uh following the cabinet's endorsement
of the revenue and capital budget for
the fourth coming year on the 17th in
january
it's been the subject of consultation
with the citizens panel the non-domestic
rate payers and the osc's task and
finish group
the outcome of these consultations have
been set out in their respective
appendices one to three to this paper
the citizens panel response generated 62
responses
small numbers of whom
individually expressed their views on a
wide variety of topics
the number and proportion of those
respondents who were supportive of the
budget's proposals overall would double
those who were not supportive
interestingly the proposal that was
opposed by the greatest number at 14
individuals
was the proposal to allocate an
additional ten thousand pounds towards
the act the fund to funding activities
surrounding the commonwealth games
at the same time the allocation of fifty
thousand pounds to the cost of dealing
with um ash dieback amongst the
council's population of ash trees met
with complete support
from all five of those who commented on
this proposal
in meeting the meeting with the
non-domestic rate payers panel was
attended by a number of people where the
section 151 officer made a presentation
and answered a series of questions
those present appreciated that the
council's role in relation to
non-domestic rates was to administer the
system rather than to set the rates to
be paid a further report on this meeting
will i believe be provided verbally
the proposed budget has also been the
subject of scrutiny at two meetings of
the osc budget task and finish group
whilst it's not the role of this task
and finish group to approve the proposed
budget it is the group's role to come to
a view as to whether the proposed budget
was financially sound and capable of
being delivered on both criteria the
group came to the view that that was
indeed the case
the task group
task and finish group also
considered a number of alternative
proposals that have been submitted by
the liberal democrat group which are set
out in paragraphs
3.3.2
of appendix ii
i'm sure members of the cabinet will now
wish to give serious consideration to
each of these proposals
it's proposed therefore that members of
the cabinet accept the recommendations
one to seven presented in the summary on
page nine of this paper that the
proposal set out in appendices 4 5 6 and
7
are approved
and that the council tax for a band d
property be increased by 5 pounds the
equivalent of a rise of 3.3 percent to
be set at 154 pounds and 12 pence with
this proportionate rate of increase
being applied to the remaining property
bans
thank you mr chairman
thank you councillor harvey
can i can i briefly say
that
can i add
that in relation to appendix 2
on page i have it as page 7
um the proposed liberal democrat budget
amendments um the first uh amendment
refers to shock mobility i'm afraid
there's a typographical error there that
it is referred to as shot mobility using
two words when indeed it is singly one
word
thank you councillor harvey
uh just a few observations from me on
the budget
uh
the economic background to the budget is
changing extremely rapidly
uh these some of the assumptions that
were made in putting the budget together
may well be
overtaken by events but the assumptions
that were made
were appropriate at the point in time
uh
i would just remind everyone that we
only received a one-year settlement
and finally the budget has adopted a
very prudent approach
which seems to be under the
circumstances where there is an enormous
amount of uncertainty to be highly
appropriate
do i have any
comments or observations from members of
covenant mr brooklyn do you want to go
thank thank you chairman leader sorry
indeed um
when councillor harvey introduced the
the did the budget referred to the
business rate paid meeting which was
held late last week which held on
thursday evening i can just give a very
quick overview of the meeting if you'd
like so we we did have um attendees from
the the country and monster growth
company um the federation of small
business and and representatives from
the shakespeare's birthplace trust who
received a presentation from from mike
snow your 6151 officer on the budget
proposals for the coming year
there was no real debate about the
individual proposals but it was a useful
form in relation to discussing issues
affecting business at the moment
including issues around inflation um and
and then the difficulty in recruiting
staff um the the group also received a
presentation from john carford on the
delivery and the processes to which we
are currently with the development of
the south share local plan and uh it was
useful for especially the fsb to be able
to feed into that particular process so
it was a useful session but there was no
no
support or otherwise in relation to the
budget proposals as laid down
thank you mr buckland i would agree i
thought it was a very useful session
uh
right members of cabinet any comments
any questions
no
oh sorry
councillor kettle and then councillor
shenton
this is really one for the portfolio
holder robin um mr harvey
there is quite a significant
increase in the budget
on
software which is separate to the half
million identified on page nine which mr
harvey referred to
which i believe is to
enhance the phones and
laptops people have
um
can we make sure that
you know there is
due consideration
that we've all got
relatively new laptops across
i think without
an exception everybody's got a pretty
new laptop on their desk that
if we are looking to uh
upgrade we don't chop the good away with
the bad
councillor harvey
is for portfolio holder mr harvey not
view
councillor shenton
that's the cargill
the mic wasn't on
noted
fine
councillor shenton
my microphone is on
um it was just clarification when we uh
when we we vote now are we also voting
for the the
amendment or the the proposals from the
dems at the same time
taking that as a separate
mr buckley german that's absolutely up
to you which the proposals which have
gone forward you wish to accept or or or
not the purpose of the meeting today is
to receive all of the results from the
consultation and for you to respond to
that consultation by making your final
recommendations from the cabinet to
council um
if some of the proposals or what none of
the proposals you accept now that that
could mean lead to um amendments being
made at their meeting the council if
they're not included
thank you mr brookland
councillor harvey do you wish to pick up
that
um
[Music]
my understanding was that we would uh
consider those four proposals at this
meeting and come to a conclusion as to
what we would be prepared to recommend
to to council
i i think that uh is what mr brookland
actually said
in which case how would you like to
conduct the debate
uh as portfolio holder do you wish to
open fine um
i have personal view on on these four
proposals um
proposal one the community zero carbon
fund
uh
allocation of 125 000 pounds
um for the as set out
i wouldn't support that because i think
that um uh there is sufficient um in the
budget already to do with climate change
uh and i i would
given the the need for caution
and and prudence given the uncertain
circumstances i wouldn't go as far as as
supporting that
um the affordable housing fifty thousand
pounds uh proposal
um
i i just don't see fifty thousand pounds
towards affordable housing achieves any
any great movement as i i don't think
that's an effective proposal to put
forward
however the practical energy advice for
residents at fifty thousand pounds i do
think there's merit in this um i'm not
sure that i go along with it 100 at this
stage because
um clearly
with what's happened to energy prices
over the last six months and the rise in
the cap we are going to face a lot of
residents who are going to have
significant problems
um
in that sense i have every every
sympathy uh for putting extra resource
in order to make sure that uh
residents are pointed to to sources of
of help either financially or in terms
of making their their properties more
energy efficient so that they can reduce
their their demand for energy
and what i'm nervous about however is
that this merely duplicates uh
activities and agencies which are
already hard at work in this particular
area
so
my view is that we should put fifty
thousand pounds for this purpose into
the budget on the basis that we can look
forward to a report from officers to
make a proposal which
sets out why
it would be a good thing to allocate
this fund for a particular purpose um
providing the background about all the
alternatives either this is worth doing
or it's not worth doing because it
really replicates if it doesn't
replicate if it can bring something new
to the party i'm in principle i'm in
favor of it so i would i would urge um
support for that
the extra business support for seventy
five thousand pounds for recovery for
for covered again at seventy five
thousand pounds i think that's a drop in
the bucket compared with the the uh
the the funds that the government has
made available in which which the
district council has administered so
successfully so i wouldn't support that
but i but i would go along with with
item proposal number three
on that basis i'm quite happy to
consider alternatives
council shenton
council harvey took almost effectively
took all my thunder there i agree uh and
i second everything that is said there
as far as the uh that the practical
energy uh goes i'd i agree we need a
business case we need to understand that
a little bit better but in theory the
merits of it seem reasonable and the
other is i don't support uh either so
i'd actually echo everything that trevor
cancer harvey has said
thank you councillor shenton
councillors unit
a couple of points if i might um one is
uh just to reiterate what i said at the
ovion scripting committee that i have
actually written as leader of the
liberal democrats to the mp uh
reiterating what um councillors here
said but also what the lga chairman has
said about the uh one-year settlement uh
being uh ineff inefficient and
ineffective you know that the government
doesn't local councils do need uh more
than one uh a settlement at a time this
is the fourth in a row uh if they are to
plan properly and to plan efficiently
and effectively um so those for those
councillors that were not the cabinet
members that were not there i have
actually said that and i believe it's a
unified view from from from everybody
on the liberal democrat um proposals
obviously we will say more at the
council um but just to say that in my
view
um making sure that communities and
village halls
are at the forefront of practical
implementation
of um
of energy efficiency and uh climate
change means that you can get into the
heart of communities
and show uh firsthand uh what uh being
energy efficient it can mean and i know
that harbory village hall for example
is one that uh is quite outstanding in
the way it has done so uh and i was
thinking that maybe if you could you
know villagers could apply for solar
panels or on charge points
and with a caveat that they um explain
two members of the public that come to
the village halls exactly why they're
doing it and what they're doing i think
it might help
um
support the whole concept of climate
change and addressing climate change it
is modeled very much on two
examples from elsewhere one of which is
south cambridgeshire district council
but others i do know do a similar thing
where they apply they have this grant
application for village halls and
community
and
organizations
the the the exact remit of how that com
those grants can be uh done are
available should you wish to do so um
the
just on the other one um the the i'm
glad that there has been some support
for the advice on ng because i do
believe we are going into a very
critical um year ahead it's not going to
be just a few months it's going to be a
critical year
when people do need to have energy
advice
there are going to be people who are
going to be really um seriously affected
and if we can provide that advice
but it's not just to individuals it's to
our housing team in particular when they
engage with people
sorry
i've got i should have had a drink
when they engage with um
residents who are coming to them with
difficulty if they could um
help and assist at that point
then we might prevent a lot of problems
arising later on with people not being
able to meet their rent or etc uh which
is a difficulty for the council and uh
should be avoided at all costs
sorry thank you
thank you very much
and finally um we'll have the debate
about um the economic strategy i'm sure
at the council i shan't kind of go on on
much longer except to just to say that
anything that can help you have a good
efficient economic strategy this you
know to help high streets and retail uh
et cetera then we're just trying to
indicate that we do support that
thank you councillor junior before i
bring in councillors pemberton and
shenton
uh i think we are all
in full agreement
of the need for four-year settlements
this continued one-year settlement does
not really enable us to plan at all
i think one of the other points you made
about energy
uh i think the energy prices are not
going to go down in a year i think we
are in for several years
and the information i read indicates
that the uh
price cap become the autumn could be in
the order of
2450 pounds
so with
council of pemberton and then councillor
shenton
thank you chairman um i think the leader
of the opposition has eloquently
outlined
why the vast majority of the proposals
advanced by the liberal democrat group
are not fully formed and couldn't
therefore be added to the budget but
within and even within the one that is i
think there is a need to have an
understanding of what can be delivered
so it would would appear that uh
everybody's on the same page that the
only one we can really progress and i
would support councillor harvey and
councillor shenton
is the one around fleshing out what we
can actually add add to the work that is
being done by other organizations
because we do have to work in
partnership with
big ticket items such as energy advice
energy poverty uh or rather fuel
positive poverty as it as it's as it's
referred to um so i think it does indeed
show um why and where there is something
there's still further work to be done so
and if the if that if the officers can
demonstrate that that 50 000 pounds
can make a difference to residents then
we will absolutely ensure that that
money is applied and delivered to make
that that that difference to our
residents so um on that basis i'm quite
comfortable with everything that the
portfolio
holder has said around amendments to the
budget
thank you council of pemberton i've got
councillor shenton and then councillor
parry
thank you leader just uh again just to
go back on the community
uh zero carbon fund um councillor june
had mentioned talks about uh communities
and village halls and and and this sort
of thing i have got i intend to bring
forward uh a few
suggestions on this to cancel myself i'm
not going to go into them now because uh
we'd be here for a while debating those
um but i have
my own thoughts on how we can achieve
what you want to achieve um without it
being in our budget
thank you council of shenzhen for
merciful shortening of the meeting
councillor parry
thank you leader um i just wanted to
confirm my agreement with what has
already been said um in support of the
proposals that have been made i also
wanted to highlight um and i agree with
the proposal to review the self-build
and custom build housing register and
delighted to be able to confirm that
this work is already well underway by
the policy team and has been done so for
the last
few
several weeks so
um
we're already doing it um and we
recognize that so
and i know it's something councillor
rock feels very passionate about um and
i'm in full agreement of what he's doing
so it is something that we are looking
at all right thank you
thank you councillor parry
so
uh the recommendations to cabinet one
and two and the recommendations to
council three four five six and seven on
page nine
have i believe being proposed by
councillor harvey and seconded by
councillor shenton
can i just check on on recommendation
four which is the proposed medium-term
revenue budget detailed appendix six it
says
um or a suitably men's version be
approved
can i assume in the korean that
particular recommended that
recommendation um as amended to include
fifty thousand pounds in yes 2223 in
respect to practical energy and finance
advice from residents
i think uh that is correct uh mr
brooklyn so with that amendment the
recommendations on page nine
one to seven
uh members of council are you in
agreement with those
thank you members of council
members of cabinet
uh
so moving on
we have the treasury management strategy
statement and the annual investment
strategy councillor harvey
thank you leader
there's an annual requirement under the
guidance issued by the department for
leveling up housing and communities for
councils to draw up and approve
an annual investment strategy that meets
the chartered institute of public
finance and accountancy's treasury
management code of practice
this council's proposed treasury
management strategy is set out on pages
81 to 117 for the fourth coming year in
appendix one
i draw to the attention of members of
the county just one aspect of this
appendix
on page 90 you'll see that the
expectation for for investment returns
in the immediate future remains low
that said we have now seen two rises in
consecutive months in bank rates to 0.5
percent the first time this has happened
since 2004.
the bank of england has serious concerns
about its ability to control inflation
in current circumstances through
monetary policy alone interest rates are
anticipated to continue to rise during
2022
albeit by modest levels by historic
standards with consequences for
borrowing costs of both individuals and
those of the government itself
whilst there is the prospect of a rise
in the council's investment returns in
2022 their scale remains both uncertain
and modest
appendix 2 on pages 119 227
sets out the proposed capital and
investment strategy for the period
2022-23 to 2025-26
this proposal provides the framework
within which it's intended that the
council should make its capital and
investment decisions
over the next five years
on the assumption that members of the
cabinet have familiar familiarized
themselves with these papers and subject
to any questions they may have i ask
that approval is given to
recommendations one to four as set out
in the summary on page 77.
thank you thank you
thank you councillor harvey
are there any questions comments from
cabinet members
i'll take that as a resounding no in
which case the recommendations
on page 77 have been proposed by
councillor harvey can i have a second to
please
uh councillor jennings
all those in favor
agreed thank you
so moving swiftly on prudential
indicators once again councillor harvey
thank you
in conjunction with considering its
budget for the forthcoming year the
council is required by the sipher
prudential code
to set prudential indicators that ensure
that its capital investment plans are
affordable prudent and sustainable
the paper under consideration sets out
the factors that the council through its
section 151 officer
is required to take into account when
considering the affordability in its
particular circumstances of its intended
capital expenditure over the period of
the medium-term financial strategy
and the affordability of the capital
financing requirement to which this
intended expenditure may give rise
members of the cabinet will have noted
that paragraphs 1.4 to 1.6
taken together
outlined the borrowing intentions that
have been approved in principle by the
council
up to
the 15.6 million pounds referred to in
paragraph 1.3
the basis upon which the prudential
indicators have been proposed in this
paper are set out in paragraph
1.11
the paper goes on to demonstrate how
these principles have been applied in
relation to the council's projected
program of capital expenditure and the
resultant estimates of how they will be
financed as set out in paragraphs 2.61
and 2.62 to demonstrate their
affordability
the cabinet is therefore asked to
approve the recommendation set out on
page one through 135 that the proposed
prudential indicators for the forth
coming year be approved
thank you leader
thank you councillor harvey
you like we have any questions any
comments observations from members of
cabinet
i don't see any can i have a second or
for counselor harvey's proposals please
thank you councillor shenton in that
case the
recommendation on page 135
are we all in agreement with that
members of cabinet
great thank you members of cabinet so
moving on
we now have um the asset decarbonisation
strategy councillor shenton
thank you chair um
mercifully for everyone i don't intend
to go through this paper either in great
detail
um
as you'll see from the papers and
understand that this particular paper is
referring to ambition one in the main
and which is the net zero carbon cancel
and it sets out to show how funds
previously agreed in when november 2021
will be utilized
some of the measures that we're
proposing are cross-cutting into
councillor barker's
portfolio as the portfolio holder for
homes health and well-being
the paper uh makes reference to warwick
district council at times and that's
because we're trying to the paper is
actually used in both and we're trying
to keep the ambitions closely aligned
we had allocated 163 000 in november
and it's these sort of funds that we're
talking about
i would add that
as per page 157 section 8.7
in the main this excludes elizabeth
house and riverside house at present
there's there have been a couple of uh
questions
asked and one was uh recently which was
how will we find the suppliers
if w if warwick district council
couldn't and that's a fair challenge
and we recognize there is a risk in
identifying suitable suppliers but maybe
with a joint approach
the search for these experts and
suppliers to conduct a study will be
more fruitful
time will tell
as also highlighted we cannot be certain
about costs and whether any work will be
affordable and at this stage as the
report highlights the details on funds
available as part of the government's
buildback greener initiative and not yet
available
but we will need to keep close to this
and as part of the agreed funding we
have at least one person who will be
looking at this closely and competing
for those available funds
and
then the other question that's been
asked is how we would fund such a
program
and uh as the paper sets out
we couldn't possibly uh fund everything
but we should prepare a shopping list of
items
um to use a a a quote um so that we have
some idea in which order fund we're not
funded funds that do become available
through the buildback greener initiative
when they become available through that
we can we are in readiness and can apply
straight away for those funds
and one of the things that we have found
is that often the time scale is very
limited um when
these funds are released or announced as
we saw with the lag scheme short window
to apply so it is only right that we
have the data and the uh and our list
ready with all the details so that we
can get in quickly
at this point i'd take you back to page
141
and ask that the recommendations number
one to five
are accepted in full subject
to any minor changes in wording that
either the portfolio holder for homes
health and well-being um kessler barker
myself or the director for climate
change dave barber agree the sort of
amendments i envisage though will be
typographical uh and terms and not not
on the thrust of the paper or the
funding itself
councillor barker i notice you're down
as portfolio holder as well is there
anything you wish to add
i can't add anything except to say lads
and suds are marvelous and we need to
keep applying for these grants because
we're very successful at getting them
thank you councillor barker councillor
pemberton
uh thank you chairman may i ask that any
typographical amendments be referred to
councillor harvey
don't
do i have any comments or input from
members of ca of cabinet
councillor kettle
thank you mr shetland for bringing it
forward um
uh sorry darren one for you though um
clearly this is what we are as a local
authority trying to achieve with our
assets and that is commendable
uh but can we be reassured in terms of
planning and planning policy
that the council does everything it can
to ensure that the private sector
particularly new developments
um
are given as much encouragement
to ensure that new properties
in this district do everything that they
can to minimize the use of fossil fuels
and to maximize
energy saving where they can
council of pemberton uh thank you
chairman yes yes i will um with the
caveat that in relation to current
development
um
there are limitations to our ambitions
by virtue of current the current policy
framework
um around the core strategy around the
climate change spd
which whilst it moved the dial forward
um
only move the dial forward because it
was in the context of the core strategy
and things such as building regulations
so uh with due difference deference to
my colleague councillor parry um
yes give you that assurance but within a
current framework but also moving
forward
this will be the umpteenth time that
i've said this the the new local plan
does and will have climate change
running through its heart if there is
you know if there is a golden thread
that will be it for the new south wales
local plan uh you are assured that dave
barber as our climate change officer is
intimately involved with
the development of the south
warwickshire local plan it's not just a
planning policy matter
we've engaged with the met office for
advice so for the avoidance of anybody
of any doubt for anybody listening out
there if you are a prospective developer
of anything other than residential homes
but that infrastructure be that
commercial development employment
anything then you need to be buying into
our climate change ambitions and you
will be held to account for that because
they will run through our new plan and
if hopefully that is the assurance that
you you require
because it is what residential homes are
a key driver for the future we cannot
and must not ignore the rest of the
built environment and its impact on
achieving our climate change ambitions
thank you councillor parry and then
councillor junior oh sorry
councillor parry councillor harvey
councillor june thank you leader and i'd
just like to endorse uh what council of
pemberton has said but also there will
be further government initiatives coming
forward with further planning reforms
and looking at energy and energy ratings
as well which will have a significant
impact on planning and design and build
later this year thank you
thank you
thank you i just wanted to endorse and
welcome councillor shinton's
comments about ambition 2 in its
achievement
in inherent in this project it seems to
me is the creation of
a wish list of of changes and
improvements which will get us towards
this the desired reduction which will be
um it'll it'll outstretch our financial
capability one way or another
i
i really wouldn't want people to be
disappointed
unduly if we have to go at a slower pace
than we would all want
simply because the finance is beyond the
means of the council and is and is not
securable from from other sources so the
the the issue here is not the degree of
ambition that we all have towards
climate change it's it's the where with
all with which to achieve it which i i i
note that councillor shenton has has
fully accepted and and will bring
forward proposals on that basis
thank you councillor harvey you make a
very very good point
uh
councillor barker then councilwood unit
i just wanted to make a point about
the kind of
solar panels and hate pumps and so on
that we get
just to support what ann is saying um
i have had
quite a lot of lobbying already from
people in the in the community where
they're finding
that their um what's it called the
epcc
that their epcs are adversely affected
by doing something that's good that's
good for the environment um and i just
flag it up
here
as well because i'm being lobbied about
it with housing but also
um the one of the people who's been in
touch with me he and i are going to get
together and maybe we need to really
talk to the government about this
because it's completely and utterly
unjoined up you get a lower
epc if you've gone for electricity
and remember
do you wish to respond on that
specifically i'd just like to interject
there i understand the government is
actually looking at how the epcs are
calculated because of the impact of the
heat pumps
deliver a lower energy performance
rating than gas
i rest my case thank you councillor
barry councillor junaid
um can i until such time as the
government comes forward with the future
homes program etc we um
we we need to do what we can within the
council what's in within the
council's gift
uh and i'm just wondering uh i heard saw
the press release that came out from
warwick district council and maybe the
officer might be able to tell me more
but it did mention that uh warwick
district was doing uh
something to make
uh um boost the
um the requirements on energy efficiency
in for new build with a i think a dbd
dpd i'm just wondering how that is
different from what stratford is doing
and whether or not it could be
replicated in stratford
mr barber do you wish to respond
uh yes happy too um yeah councillor
junior is absolutely right uh warwick
district council going to its cabinet
this week has a report that um
proposes a consultation on a uh
net zero carbon buildings development
plan document so this is a document that
has the same status as say the local
plan policies do um it still needs to go
through a further round of consultation
and an examination in public but the
intention would be to
have it adopted within
the year um within a winner within about
a year uh and that will then place
additional requirements on developers in
warwick district um the intention um in
all of the discussions that i've been
involved with is that um that policy
will form a
um
a core part of the uh southwestern local
plans um net zero carbon but what
climate change policies um
and has the potential to be sort of
rolled into the into the southwest your
local plan um as and when that's
prepared
thank you mr barber uh councillor
pemberton
thank you um
to be honest counselor junior i'm
getting i am tired of this
comparing us to warwick
we've been through this and i'm i'm sure
i had we had this conversation nearly 12
months ago we were in a different policy
framework environments warwick
we have gone as far as our core strategy
will allow us to go
there was a debate about whether a dpd
would be
drafted by this authority and given the
fact that we were moving to a local plan
the local plan was decided to be the
better shorter route
warrick are in a different policy
framework position and have taken a
different approach
the net effect however will be that the
vast majority of that work
will be subsumed into the local plan but
the fact remains that they could move in
a different way and i said right at the
get-go that the supplementary planning
document around climate change would not
get us to where we wanted to be and that
the only answer from the start point
that we had is the local plan and and so
to be honest i am tired of this
we knew this was coming everybody knew
this was coming and everybody knew they
were not quite in the same
space as us so
to suggest can we then go back and can
we do a little bit more i
our officers are doing absolutely
everything possible to get us to a point
where we can have a policy framework
that achieves our ambitions as early as
possible members across both authorities
are joined at the hip about that as an
expiration and a delivery and officers
are doing that as well so i get that and
i get that it sounds really good to
suggest we're dragging our feet but the
blunt truth is we're not
um and we will get there we have to
start from the policy framework that we
had not the one we wished we had
counseled
yeah just
my apologies i i just want wondered
whether
there could be lessons that could be
useful to this council in the local plan
uh and um
i think that is something that could be
done and is could be supported by
everybody um so i'm sorry that i'm upset
the the portfolio holder i think council
of pemberton has covered the point in
that it will be picked up and will fade
into the south wallach local plan
i see no one else wishing to comment so
the recommendations
one to five on page 141
i believe these are being proposed by
councillor shenton and seconded by
councillor kettle
so can i have your agreement to
the recommendations on page 141 members
of cabinet
thank you
mr buckland do you want to come in
thank you chairman it wasn't on item
eight it actually relates to item six
and item seven the treasury management
strategy and the prudential indicators
they're shown on the agenda and within
the packs as being resolved by kavanaugh
although we have traditionally taken
these items to council so
given that you've already considered
them i wonder whether you would be
minded to um change them to
recommendations to council please rather
than a resolution here
members of cabinet are you willing to
change that to being referred to council
thank you members of cabinet
so moving on
uh part c issues arising from the review
and scrutiny committee thank you um
thank you um leader so it's just to
reiterate
what council harbis already says the
budget task and finish group reported
back to us and they were satisfied that
the budget proposals both um that the
liberal democrats were clear achievable
and financially sound and we've already
gone through that um members were fully
cognizant of the fact that this local
government um receiving only one year
settlement had to be reflected
throughout the budget proposals i'd like
to
have my thanks to councillor harvey
noted um it's been reported back to me
that your session was
with bringing pretty dense and fact-rich
information was presented in a really
user-friendly way that members were very
grateful for and that they found your q
a session as a portfolio holder really
helpful and the fact that prudent by the
prudent budget was being designed within
the constraints the one-year settlement
they found your reasoning behind it
really enlightening that's feedback i've
had so can i thank you for the time you
put into attending the meeting
um members of the committee raised
concerns over
the
loan to the spring housing association
um just around the financial
possibilities of being paid back
um and also around the gateway project
and then we're going to go into private
session over this but the questions just
raised about the influence that sdc
would have
i think uh council donald summer this
might be best for the private section
there's nothing else that's not just
like
i think i did mention because i was
aware that we're going into that that's
how i was commenting on it
okay so moving on
uh unblock items uh
we have the cabinet work program
we have the stratfor
stratford-upon-having markets forum
and
then
under urgent business we have a paper on
the fred winter center mr brookland
chairman uh firstly thank you for
considering this urgent item this
afternoon and councillor o'donnell thank
you for considering it and allowing it
to be considered at the cabinet this
afternoon
there's a proposition in front of you
this afternoon to consider the grants
never loan of 185 000 pounds of spring
housing to enable the completion of the
fred winter center
the fred winter center is a scheme that
worked the council has been supporting
now for a number of years
and will have massive benefits for the
authority and for
the individuals who will be using the
facilities and then these are some of
the most troubled within our communities
some of our homelessness communities who
will
enter into a full programme of support
to help them rebuild their lives
the scheme was anticipated originally to
cost around three million pounds
due in the main two additional fire
measures which had to be put in police
after the scheme had
progressed mainly due to the
recommendations from the grenfell
inquiry the scheme costs are now in the
order of 3.4 million pounds spring
housing themselves have identified
around 215 000 pounds worth of
additional funding to help fund these
additional improvements which are needed
to the facility and they have approached
us with the view to
supporting them with a loan of 185 000
to be repairable over two and a half
years
i'll absolutely concur with the comments
that council o'donnell made around
the skepticism surrounding the
affordability of spring housing to
repay
the loans um
we've checked we we've engaged with
their their their lead officer and had
assured this i don't know
mike snow might be able to say a bit
more on that i know he's received some
uh correspondence from them
they they do wish
that if they do identify funding
earlier than the the end of the two and
a half years that they could have the
ability to repay the loan early i don't
think would would resist that at all um
but really it's a recommendation that
i'm bringing forward for you this
afternoon to enable the completion of
the center that we grant this loan as
requested thank you chairman
thank you mr brooklyn mr snow do you
have anything to add
uh well the only bits i can really add
is yes we've had some more information
just to try to support the application
from spring um in terms of things like
the updated cash flow
for the spring housing association which
you know looks positive and doesn't give
any race
any cause for concern
and also we've had their latest draft
accounts their accounts the last set of
accounts
or their latest accounts haven't yet
been quite signed off by the auditors
it's still slightly early but we've
they've made the the draft accounts to
available to us and again there's
nothing
adverse within those that raises any
concern so yeah so
you know based on that we you know we're
reasonably comfortable that you know
they should be able to
um accommodate and repay the loan on the
basis proposed
thank you mr snow it's reassuring to
know that you are probing extremely
effectively
councillor barker
um i just want to um endorse the need
for
this to be given for the sake of uh
hapleth of something we shouldn't let
the boat sink or some other
phrase like that i can't have the tar i
believe um
the 185 000 i'm quite convinced um needs
to be spent in order that we can deliver
this project and things have changed and
that's that's the problem with the fire
x
so i'm really comfortable that we do it
and they're going to deliver a good job
we also
desperately need the accommodation so
that we stop putting people into bmvs
because
however
well-accommodated people may be and they
have been particularly during lockdown
um this is the way that we need to do it
to help actually get people off the
streets keep them off the streets and we
hope help them sort their lives out
so i endorse it
thank you councillor barker councillor
harvey
i have in the past being known to be
critical about lending money that we're
not a banker
as a district council but in this
particular instance i'm i'm more than
happy that this should
should go through and i'm
unlike other
other previous instances we will know
fairly certain uh early on that a
monthly schedule of repayments is being
kept too so i'm quite comfortable i just
wanted to point out a a minor suggestion
on 6.1
where the comment is made the resource
will provide a unique and valuable
resource to the town and i think it's to
the district as a whole because i
wouldn't want our friends
in
napton and southam to think to think
that this is purely a stratford-centric
uh proposition this is a facility
this this is this is a facility that is
meant to support those who are
unfortunate to find themselves in
homeless circumstances anywhere in the
district it's not just in stratford
your point is well made councillor
harvey and very much noted councillor
pemberton
thank you chair just to um
for everybody's benefit when this
project was
first mooted and came in it's in
in its infancy to the housing investment
panel for the initial round of support
it was uh and still remains
um
pitched and will deliver a district-wide
service
so i think that everybody
everybody understands it is a
district-wide i know it's centered in
tan but
anybody
who can benefit from
the provision that the fred winter
centre will provide across this district
will be able to access those services um
and this is nothing other than
um
absolutely what we must do because it
will too to many degrees sort of be a
really big step forward to to ending the
scourge of homelessness in this district
particularly for the most vulnerable and
hard to reach and support so um
let's go to the recommendation
thank you councillor pemberton uh i
believe councillor barker you proposed
the uh recommendation and council of
pemberton i believe from what you just
said you are very definitely second in
it
uh can i have your agreement to the
uh proposal the recommendation to
council then
on the uh urgent item sheet all those in
favor
great thank you members of cabinet
so now we return to uh item four
the
gateway purchase options and do you wish
to make a brief introduction to this
paper mr perks
just we will just do a very brief intro
from mr perks and then we will go
because once you start getting into the
debate
we inevitably will pick up the exact
dependencies
then we will move into a private session
thank you leader and it's by way of
introduction on this project um
should i start again
um
for the benefits of those listening
yes
i've got to try and say the same thing
twice now
um
thank you thank you leader
thank you mr perks
the paper that you have um
presented before you today sets out an
option to secure the land
known as the gateway site in
stratford-upon-avon which sits at the
junction of arden street in birmingham
road and runs through to the top of
henley street through our windsor street
car park
it is a site that we've been looking at
for some considerable time with the
current owner to sort of try and secure
a more pleasant approach to that key
entrance to stratford and to link
through to the canal quarter
most recently it was subject to a bid to
the leveling up fund with the potential
to achieve a world shakespeare center on
that site a project that some stimulated
quite a lot of sort of national regional
interest and has the potential to help
sort of in our transformation of
stratford as a town for the 21st century
um the paper sets up a number of options
of acquiring that from its current owner
peter warwick and with that i would
suggest perhaps we move into
confidential session to have further
discussions
thank you mr perks before we move into
private session and i read the words i
would just like to actually
uh
give my thanks for all the work that
you've put into this because it has not
been the easiest thing to tackle
so with that i would like the recording
in the minutes please on
uh
fine
right
this is about exclusion of the public
and it is that pursuant to section 100 a
brackets four of the local government
act 1972
as amended the public be excluded from
the remaining business of the meeting in
view of the fact that the nature of the
proceedings will be such that if the
public were present there would likely
be disclosure to them of exempt
information under paragraphs three and
five of part one of schedule 12a to the
said act brackets as amended
so with that let me just give it a
couple of minutes
chairman you need a chairman you just
need a resolution to that effect so if
you could just put that to them
i have
a second for that please
thank you
councillor harvey
uh all those in favour
great thank you
we're just going to enter my team i
think
and as soon as a live feed ends we can
go into discussion